please welcome the one and only the
funny the brilliant craig robinson
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
hello
craig
when did you burst onto the scene
because i could swear it was easily
40-something years ago like i don't
remember
life without you
but sometimes when i look at your resume
and i'm like oh like you didn't start
40-something years ago i i got to
hollywood in uh
1999
and i think the the office was about
2004. well that is a long time ago now
if you think about it
but you did stand up
i do stand up still i mean yeah exactly
and is it true that there's something
like of a story of stand up x a rubber
chicken
oh yeah oh
uh when i was getting started there was
this
place in chicago uh
they had a night called heckler's heaven
and
you got three minutes okay of nobody
bothering
and then you had eight minutes
total
if you didn't get a rubber chicken three
people in the audience had a rubber
chicken
so once they once that three-minute bell
hit if somebody wants to throw a rubber
chicken at you you have to get off stage
and uh
i got i got two rubber chickens i said
i'm not getting a third
so i got off and then the next week i
came back with my keyboard and that's
all she wrote now do stand up with the
keyboard
[Applause]
i guess it like sharpens your skills
well it certainly keeps you on your toes
yeah to uh to get to the jokes is it
true that you have written yourself
notes um
about kind of where you want to go in
life and if so why do you do that i i
love this
when i was uh i remember being
you know i was in college that's when i
was uh
i felt like comedy chose me
and uh and i wrote a note to myself
because i was getting i knew i was
getting the comedy and i said you are
going to be a great comedian and i i
crossed out going to me
and said you are a great comedian
i
really think
that words matter absolutely and a turn
of phrase a choice of words pulling out
going to be rather than i am
those things i think
are like inextricably linked with belief
for sure
[Music]